[Musique]
rangez-le et ils vous gouvernent avec
la lumière du soleil
et il n'y a rien que je veuille faire quand je
veux un peu de tranquillité d'esprit
laissez la fumée monter vraiment
même commence à
Charice bien un plus doux c'est le ciel
[Musique]
laissez le Sinaï
vous tous
[Musique]
il n'y a pas d'endroit comme l'avenue quand
la musique s'empare de vous
conduire pour
oublier le Bubba
trop à
supporter  comme une
musique
donc moi-même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Steve jetant à la batterie
[Musique]
donc
Je ne sais pas
[Musique]
toi
[  Musique]
wastin away
ne perdez pas l'enfant
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas passé
façon que
nous connaissons le plus au monde
[Musique]
Oh
le nombre
Non
[Applaudissements]
sans aucun moyen
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh boy
[Musique]
Non,
nous avons perdu
[Musique]
nous serons en bas je  n le matin,
j'aime prendre juste une seconde ici pour
présenter tout le monde dans la pensée une
fois puisque c'est notre toute première fois
à Paris ici de l'autre côté de
la scène à la guitare et au chant de
Glasgow en Ecosse notre nouveau McIntyre
[Musique]
guitare venez pour ce côté éloigné de la
scène ici
Je tourne le saxophone
Molly Duncan sur le saxophone alto Roger
mesdames et messieurs les cors Dundee
[Musique]
lundi honza Roger Bobb Molly Duncan
[Applaudissements]
nous avons
fini je me promène  ici à la guitare au chant principal
également de Glasgow mr.  Hamish
[Musique]
célèbre péjoratif
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas été absents
Oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[  Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]